CNN put up a video yesterday about a
family that is fleeing Florida because
of how how evil
and of course transphobic Florida is
it's it's a two-parter here's part one
we just thought it would be a nice warm
place to live where we could get to
beaches
I just never thought that I would have
to flee a state for the good of my
children
the SB 254 this will permanent Outlaw
the mutilation of miners
I remember Tori coming to me one time
and in tears what she doesn't normally
do and I asked her what was wrong and
she said to Santas and like the fact
that a governor would be making my kid
cry that's a messed up government
we're absolutely moving because of the
political climate and the laws in
Florida we didn't want to move when the
Florida Board of Medicine started
meeting and we realized that they were
going to ban gender affirming care for
kids that we might need to leave because
that is life-saving essential medicine
and treatment for our daughter
I was very relieved when we decided to
leave I had never really heard that much
about trans people and until I was like
11 or 12 I didn't even know trans people
existed so I was just used to being
uncomfortable I started hormone blockers
pretty soon after that
yeah I mean there was times before she
started getting hormones and stuff that
she was suicidal but after she
transitioned she was much more outgoing
much more like comfortable with herself
okay that's only part one first off
before I say anything or make any
sarcastic or glib remarks and talk about
the general insanity and that CNN is
pushing this in everything else this has
nothing to do with this kid right like
I'm not making fun of this kid and I
actually have great sympathy for this
kid not exactly for the reasons that CNN
wants you to think you should have
sympathy for this kid but for what the
parents have done for this kid for what
the world and the culture has done to
this kid and all of those things there's
so much Insanity there first off that
the woman says you know she walks in one
day Tori walks in one day what's wrong
DeSantis like it's just made of what's
what's wrong what's wrong DeSantis
Ronald just said this like okay it's
just made up dribble this thing about
gender affirming care as you guys know
it's not affirming to chop off a child's
genitals that would be I don't know
unaffirming let's say and
that at 11 years old I had never heard
much the kid says I had never heard much
about trans stuff then 11 years old then
they say soon after on hormone blockers
oh so do you think there might be a
social contagion element to it suddenly
you're at school and everyone's telling
you how great trans stuff is you're 11
years old you're confused about your
body your life all of the things yada
yada yada next thing you know they're
putting you on drugs and literally
chopping your genitals off and they're
framing this as positive and that the
state that's trying to stop these kids
from having their lives and bodies
destroyed is negative anyway here's part
two
there
[Music]
we are seeing many families that are
leaving I really think if you were to
ask a member of a trans family they
would tell you they go to bed at night
dreaming of how to get out of the state
I uh feel really bad for the people that
have to stay here it's been difficult to
access my hormones I'm not honestly sure
how I would continue at access care even
if I wasn't trans I wouldn't be
comfortable here it's just not a safe
environment for queer people in general
it's just so sad that our country and
our society are in this place of
denigrating people like that and making
them feel like they have no place it's
just hard to start over all over again
foreign
guys this is exactly like that level of
propaganda that you just saw there and
that they're attacked and all of this
stuff in Florida is not safe for queer
people and and that somehow chopping
genitals is good and and dealing with
deep psychological issues somehow he's
not all of the nonsense